there's thomas esterman four starts this
year you see the record
16 innings pitched five walks and five
strikeouts not going to strike out a lot
of guys but typically control
is the key for eschmann involved in two
strikes against tim anderson
that's a left center field mullins comes
over and he makes the catch went away
johan moncotto is one two and a breaking
ball is hit in the air to left
center field stewart to his left makes
the catch from left
two batters two fly outs for thomas
eschelman and we'll send up
jose abreu that's it on the ground in
the third
gutierrez is there thomas zesha middle
one two
three first inning lucas gialito on for
his 18th start that's a whole lot of
work his era a touch over four
116 strikeouts 98 and two thirds innings
he is one of the four in the starting
rotation with over a hundred strikeouts
cedric mullins and ops over a thousand
at home that's fourth in the american
league
mullins cranks this one out to left and
it gets past vaughan
mullins digging for second and he is
there
standing up for the double
[Applause]
sliders strike three good stuff from geo
there
pairing the change up with the slider
for the last two strikes in the at-bat
anthony sunton dare the 26-year-old
switch hitter
andrew vaughn has out number two there
is some power in this bat of mount
castle
o2 slider bounce to third burger across
the way and he's got out number three
nicely done by geo
good one he's been the cleanup man here
for about a week
the payoff hit in the air deep right
center
way back there it is gone
brian goodwin with a leadoff homer here
in the second
his fourth of the season and it's one
nothing white sox all kinds of on time
on that swing
so they've got the early lead that rbi
brings a run home
that was a 3-2 slider and it didn't do a
whole lot
three and two ashleyman struck him out
wins down to second base strike
him out throw him out yup and it
wouldn't have mattered anyway because i
think we had catches interference as
well because garcia looked like he's
swung and missing and fell across home
play can frame balls and watch him come
out of that crouch
and throws a rock and you can see home
plate umpire right away
mike malinsky calls interference but it
didn't matter and i'm talking about by
about six feet
goal and two on stuart his first action
of the series
or a high fastball for you just for fun
one down second strikeout for lucas one
on one out for domingo
laba and he swings and lines to abraham
that's going to be a double play
he applies the tag on urias who was
standing right behind him
and that'll do it in the second the
chance for a handful here
in the third tim anderson's just the guy
to do it
first base side that is fair down the
line the ball boy just picked up the
ball just keep running
and so the socks are gonna get a run i
mean
it's gonna be a double the umpires are
gonna say
one run it looks like right now not many
people feel worse in the ballpark than
this young man
and then he can't then he he can't get
rid of the evidence yeah
he tries to hide the evidence and it
comes back to him
tim driving in his 32nd it's two to
nothing nobody out runners at second and
third and now the infield has to come in
as this one ends up in right field and
that one will go to the wall untouched
by human hands
it is a two-run double for joan monkatta
and it's four nothing socks still nobody
out in the third so keegan
he's come on he's now gotten two outs
and it's going to send
laurie garcia up to the plate he's out
of the game
garcia is a strikeout victim but the
white sox do some damage in their half
of the third
lucas giolito will work to calvin
gutierrez
3-2 fastball got him on the inside
corner
third strikeout for geo the leadoff man
cedric mullins
strike three on a change-up good
sequence from geo
to get rid of mullins anthony santander
will bat with two away and two on
runners on second and third for the
orioles
swing and a miss he got him on a change
up good pitching by lucas giolito to get
his
fifth strikeout of the afternoon so one
down for stewart who lucas dispatched
very quickly last time
change up for strike three a wave and a
miss he waited
and waited and didn't wait long enough
as it dropped out of the zone two outs
in a man in scoring position for leyba
hits this one into right that is down
they're going to give the send to mount
castle throw coming home
cut off and the orioles on the boards so
leyba went to the right side the first
time
and lined out here he singles and brings
in the orioles first run
here's the 2-2 swing and a miss down
goes gutierrez
one run across white sox
four orioles one two one nobody out
batter will be brian goodwin
goodwin to first base and that trickles
on through
monkatta from third comes home and the
sox
have a 5-1 lead getting the run right
back from the o's
there's a swing and a liner out toward
the alleyway and left center
here comes abraham he will score garcia
on his way to second he's got a standing
double
he found the seam out in the deep part
of the ballpark
and he makes it 6-1 6-1
white sox bottom five one two home
swing and a miss for strike three
eight strikeouts now for g alito back to
work giolito the 3-2
swing and a miss got him on a slider
he's got nine
punch outs through five sixth inning
lucas giolito's allowed only one run
on six hits three and two to mount
castle and he hits this ball into left
vaughn is back at the track and he makes
the catch
fall four here comes tony larussa
we will get a pitching change well urias
hit a ground ball last time
struck him out with a cutter he
handcuffed him
on the outer third and there are two
down two going to the inning now
and here's leiba and he's got
another one just over the outstretched
glove
of anderson and the orioles have got two
runs courtesy of lebanon
check swing he went strike three and
that will do it for the o's
it'll bring up brian goodwin he has
homer has an rbi
single kelvin gutierrez the only guy on
the left side
brian goodwin drives it through that
shift
on a 3-2 pitch abreu comes home to score
and the white sox lead it 7-2 let's load
up the bases with two outs
gonna be austin hayes
runners go again it's low and ruins
walks in a run
so jose ruiz he'd walk three batters
in his previous 12 games he has walked
three in this inning and now forced home
a run base is still loaded in a five run
game
is liam hendrix and he inherits the
bases loaded
it's a fastball and away with him liam
hendricks
he shows up and three bolts
out of here here's santander with two
down
hendricks ready here's the pitch swing
and a miss
white sox win liam hendricks closes up
shop and the sox have won
four straight games on the road trip